Speaker 1: I don't want to spend a ton of
time on this, but I do want to just point
out that this NFL football player, Aaron Rodgers,
is continuing to spread straight up baseless
COVID disinformation, and the guy is a role
model to so many people.
You know, when I was a kid, I read this book
by Charles Barkley, former basketball player,
about how he really shouldn't be a role model.
He behaves in certain ways because he knows
he is as a guy who's who's in sports.
But that really these people should not be
role models and that there was truth to that
in the 90s.
It's so much more true today.
Here is Aaron Rodgers now on The Pat McAfee
Show saying that the COVID fact checks about
do vaccines work and stuff like that.
They're all done by Big Pharma, so you can't
trust any of them.
Speaker 2: I will say I don't believe that
hatred and fear and name-calling in any of
this stuff is going to get us out of this
pandemic.
It's going to be love and connection and conversation
and debate and information sharing and not
information sharing.
That's fact checked by the same professionals
who are, you know, running the pharmaceutical
industry.
Speaker 1: He wants information shared that
is not being fact checked.
That is fascinating, right?
Speaker 2: Oh, which is a lot of a lot of
the, you know, when you when you look into
some of those connections, it is interesting
to see some of the connections between fact
checkers and boards.
Speaker 1: And this guy thinks he's absolutely
brilliant guys.
He thinks he's figured out the ultimate truth,
and he even delivers it in this town where
it's he's not taking pleasure, but we can't
have fact checks from Big Pharma, the vaccine
of which there have been.
Is it hundreds of millions or have we gotten
to a billion doses given the vaccines have
been studied in randomized controlled trials
in all sorts of different countries by people
not associated with big pharma in the journals,
they disclose their conflicts of interest
studies on do masks work?
They've been randomized, controlled, you know,
et cetera, et cetera.
And this guy was almost the permanent Jeopardy
host, and he's going around spreading the
stuff.
As a reminder, here is the same guy Aaron
Rodgers admitting he took medical advice from
Joe Rogan when he got COVID.
And even Pat McAfee couldn't, could, couldn't
contain his laughter.
When that was mentioned, I
Speaker 2: consulted with a now good friend
of mine, Joe Rogan, right after he got COVID,
and I've been doing a lot of this stuff that
he recommended in his podcasts.
And on the phone to me, and I'm going to have
the best immunity possible now I can.
Speaker 1: So that's that was that.
Also more recently, he said, Aaron Rodgers
said that there were people watching the Green
Bay Packers and rooting against the Green
Bay Packers only because of his vaccination
status, which actually may be true.
But they're not.
They're not like the normal football fans.
There's no doubt that there are people who
had no clue who Aaron Rodgers was.
They found out he was saying very strange
things about COVID and they were rooting for
him to lose.
That's not wrong.
I think he's right about that.
Speaker 2: There were a ton of people tuning
in rooting against us for one reason and one
reason only.
It's because of, you know, my vaccination
status and them wanting to see us lose so
they could pile on and and enjoy and revel
in the fact that, you know, my vaccination
status was, you know, some sort of reason
why we haven't had the success in the playoffs
or whatever.
It might be some sort of correlation.
Speaker 1: Yeah.
Now I didn't hear that one.
So so, you know, there's always this self-importance
to these guys, even just the way that he talks.
There's this air of self-importance.
It's true that there are some people who.
Wanted to see Aaron Rodgers lose because they
think he's a prick.
I mean that that that's the long and short
of it.
I have not heard anyone say that the reason
the Green Bay Packers didn't do better is
because he's unvaccinated just doesn't.
It doesn't make any sense.
I've not heard anyone say that it doesn't
really pass the sniff test that anybody would
say that.
And the really tragic thing here is, you know,
we laugh when Aaron Rodgers says, Well, the
advice I got is from Joe Rogan.
And even Pat McAfee, who seems to go with
a lot of the things Roger says is like, Oh
God, we laugh at that, but.
There's so many people that don't listen to
doctors and they don't listen to epidemiologists,
and they don't listen to public health officials.
They listen to Joe Rogan.
And if Aaron Rodgers wants to start giving
advice about COVID treatment, they'll listen
to Aaron Rodgers as well.
And that's the real tragedy of what it is
that is going on here.
Let me know your thoughts.
Were you rooting for Aaron Rodgers to lose
because of his vaccine status?
You can let me know on Twitter where you can
find me at David Pakman and you can also find
me on Instagram at David Pakman.
We have a great Friday show for you today.
We will be on the ground at the Trump rally
in Conroe, Texas, tomorrow.
Hope you'll be following that live stream!
Stay with us!
Quick break and right back.
Remember that the David Pakman show does depend
on the support of viewers and listeners who
get memberships at join Pacman dot com.
It is a direct method of support.
It's not.
You get $100 cable bill and four bucks goes
to Fox News and it no, no, you just you sign
up at join Pacman dot com and you're saying
this is the one show I am supporting here.
And you can use the coupon code.
Wow.
22.
Twenty two to get a large discount off of
your membership.